he calls himself the social scientist
you may think of him and his economist
what's undeniable is he's a celebrity
because of his book capital in the 21st
century professor you'll face some
criticism it's fair to say that if you
can do the research and write the book
all over again what would you do
differently well you know this was so
recent that you know at this stage I
would not I don't see what I will really
do differently in fact there's been no
there's been step a step back there's
been some new data which actually
reinforced you know some of my
conclusions you know the in particular
has been a new study by esaias and
Rickman and the evolution of wealth
inequality in the United States and if
anything you know what they find is an
even bigger a rise in Wells
concentrations and what I report in my
book so you know if I was to change some
of the figures in my book I will
probably change that one and I will have
a rise in in wealth inequality that what
I am but you know in the future that
would be more data for other countries
and maybe some of them will go in the
other direction you know as new data
comes in we will update all the series
you know online this is a country in
which arguments tend to become polarized
very quickly people fall in love with
their dogma are you worried that you're
just preaching to the converted and not
enough people are reading your book and
changing their view you know I receive
lots of message email and I see lots of
people when I sign books in bookshops of
people you know we're not particularly
left-wing or not particularly right-wing
or not particularly economist certainly
and we use the swing vote would yeah we
don't usually read that kind of book and
we seem to you know to have learned you
know by reading this book and ultimately
you know this is what makes me you know
very happy which is that I have tried
you know to contribute to make these
economic issues accessible to more
people because you know these are very
important issues they should not be left
just to the you know and full of
economists and you know that's what this
book is about here's what I'd like to
know what do you do for an encore
what do I need an encore okay what will
I do you know and now I am moving more
and working on emerging countries so
working and China India you know Africa
Latin America because this is you know
we have less data for these countries
and for developed countries so we are
trying with my colleague to move in this
direction and it's not only having more
data it's also to better understand you
know the kind of political debate and
policy debates that you have for
instance in China right now there is
growing attention to the issue of wealth
inequality so so far they have been
solving the problem mostly on a case by
case basis you know when someone gets
really to which they expropriate in but
you know they are starting to realize
that this is not the right way to solve
and to regulate the dynamics of capital
accumulation so they are they are
talking about introducing some form of
property or well stacks right now and
you know I'm going to return to China
very soon and you know that's something
I want to explore so in the future
academics politics doesn't hold any
appeal for you you've been an advisor to
ségolène hi al no not really
you know I was just not convinced by
Sarkozy which is a different matter you
know I've never been an advisor to
anyone you know I've been an academic
I've been writing books and I think I
will keep writing books you know I seen
books you know can be quite powerful you
know I believe in the power of ideas I
believe in the power of books and you
know you know everybody is doing
politics I mean everybody is trying to
promote you know the social good you
know in its own way and you know I think
there are other ways to promote the
social good and to do politics and being
a politician if Hillary Clinton were to
call you and ask you to become an
economic advisor to her in what we
believe to be for effort to win the
White House in 2016 would you take the
job well I would certainly talk to her
because you know I'm a polite person and
she can always talk I always talk no
she's not coming I always talk to people
who ask to talk to me well most people
that is
but you know I don't think I would like
to become a full-time advisor you know I
think I'm happy to do it all to
contribute to the conversation but I
think you know there's a role for
different group of people and I think
you know there's a role for you know
academics to do their job to collect
data to take time because this takes a
lot of time you know I need quiet days
quiet week quiet months and you know I'm
happy of course to talk today in your
show and to do publicity for the book
but you if I want to write new books I
need to have quiet times at my office
and and you know I think that's what I
am best at and so I think I will keep
doing that in the future